[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne ferai pas le catalogue des œuvres
de mon invité il y en a trop je ne
dirais pas non plus qu'il est un auteur
prolifique il n'aime pas beaucoup les
expression non ce que je peux dire en
revanche peut-être c'est qu'il fait de
la philosophie en dessinant ou du dessin
en philosophant comprenez en tout cas
que son œuvre est profonde et qu'elle
nous fait réfléchir son coup de crayon
n'a rien de réaliste mais son trait
énergique et tout en méandre dit tout de
notre réalité de notre rapport à la vie
à la mort aux religion des relations
entre les peuples entre les cultures
entre les sexes il apporte beaucoup au
monde avec ses bandes dessinées ses
carnets ses romans ses films il lui
donne du piment du celle du sarcasme de
la lucidité de l'ironie aussi sur des
choses simples que nous vivons tous que
l'on aime ou pas son écriture son style
son dessin on est quoi qu'il arrive
percuté bouleversé on sort différent de
la lecture de ces œuvres et lui est-il
percuté par nous par les humains par la
vie sort-il différent de la réalité que
nous vivons comment sort-il par exemple
de cette journée du 7 octobre 2023 qui
marquera un tournant dans l'histoire du
monde et qui lui a inspiré une aquarelle
devenue virale un mot hébreu qui
signifie vivant posons-lui toutes ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde à
regard bienvenue à vous Johann SAR merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ici au
dô Tournon est-ce qu'il y aura pour vous
personnellement un avant et un après c
octobre
2023 c'est difficile de répondre en une
phrase en tout cas il y a eu un un
traumatisme mondial dans la communauté
juive la certitude que au-delà des
horreurs séculaires du conflit du Proche
Orient a eu lieu dans le sud d'Israël le
le le plus grand massacre de juifs
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale avec
des méthodes qui rappellent les inside
open avec des des méthodes
exterminatoires et et ça nous sort de
l'histoire du Proche-Orient pour nous
replonger dans la la fragilité du destin
juif il est très difficile de de garder
ça en tête de faire le deuil de cette
histoire tout en gardant gardant sa
raison quand on envisage les force en
présence au Proche Orient et la
nécessité de d'être capable de pleurer
pour les morts des deux camps quel est
l'istire de cette aquarelle qui semble
vous venir assez vite lorsque le drame a
lieu à partir du 7
octobre comment elle vous vient quelle
est son histoire à cet aqu c'est c'est
une une étrange coïncidence pour ma bar
mitva quand j'ai eu 13 ans pour ma
communion j'ai pas pu avoir un rail ou
une étoile de David parce que mon père
trouvait que c'était pas élégant et il
disait les nazis nous ont déjà mis une
étoile on va pas la mettre
volontairement et là j'ai fêté mes 52
ans enfin l'anniversaire s'est fait le 7
octobre et j'avais dessiné le bijou que
je voulais commander je voulais le bijou
que j'ai pas pu avoir pour ma Barva je
voulais un rail parce que juste ça veut
dire la vie ça veut pas dire nous
vaincrons ça veut juste dire la vie et
et j'ai fait ce dessin en préparant mon
anniversaire et on a appris les
nouvelles du massacre et et j'ai juste
écrit cela veut dire nous vivrons parce
que j'essayais de rappeler que le le à
ma connaissance l'objectif du peuple
juif n'est pas de vaincre quiconque mais
c'est juste de survivre et ce que j'ai
constaté c'est les gens qui veulent pas
de Juifs au ProcheOrient en général n'en
veulent pas ailleurs non plus et voilà
donc je l'ai fait pas de manière
idéologique mais de manière oui
émotionnel je précise pour les gens qui
nous écoutent qu'il y a une
manifestation devant le Sénat d'où le
bruit qui peut y avoir lors de cette
interview et et et je je demande pardon
au public pour ce bruit qui peut être un
peu gênant mais on va se concentrer sur
vos propos un jour vous avez dit il y a
une véritable jouissance dans le dessin
même quand il s'agit de scène atroce par
le dessin sans le faire exprès
j'adouciis dessiner une chose atroce
c'est la rendre regardable j'utilise le
dessin pour démystifier est-ce que vous
les avez déjà dessiné les scènes du 7
octobre 2023 non ça je n'en suis pas
capable également parce que je ne les ai
pas vu en revanche je suis capable de
dessiner les paramédiques les légistes
et et et les gens de on appelle ça la
revra Kadicha je connais pas le mot en
français les les gens qui se sont
occupés des corps ça je suis capable de
dessiner les témoignages l'z fait oui ça
je l'ai fait j'ai mis en ligne des parce
que parfois vous savez fa DESC un
massacre tout de suite les gens vont
dire c'est pas vrai vous avez inventé
donc on on a tendance à vouloir montrer
les photos et les films des massacres
moi j'ai le sentiment que la vérité au
sens journalistique ne vient plus par
les images mais vient par des Témo
témoignages recoupés par des médecins
par des enquêteurs par des légistes et
là le le dessin peut avoir un rôle
citoyen qui consiste à transmettre un
témoignage l'autre chose aussi c'est que
quand le réel est est trop chocquant
pour être regardé le dessin d'abord
explique mais également permet de
l'emprasser de manière plus
intellectuelle et moins vicérale je je
quand dans d'autres de mes ouvrages dans
les enfants ne se laissaient pas faire
j'ai parlé de la Choa parbal dessiner
des photos de de de massacre de la
deuxème guerre mondiale c'est les rendre
regardables pour un examen
journalistique et historique c'est les
sortir de de l'horreur pulsionnelle de
la photographie vous qui interrogez
beaucoup notre rapport à la religion
notamment au travers du Chat du Rabin
qu'est-ce qu'il dirait le chat du Rabin
sur ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce qu'il
dirait de la religion est-ce que il
mettrait en cause la religion là aussi
pas pas pas de manière aussi directe moi
je crois que le même si c'est peu
audible aujourd'hui le Maghreb a
beaucoup à nous enseigner tout
simplement parce que les population
maghrébine qu'elle soit musulmane juive
ou chrétienne n'ont pas choisi de vivre
ensemble et ont réussi il y a jamais eu
d'âge d'or au maghreèb ça c'est jamais
bien passé mais au moins on ne se
massacrait pas trop et dans cette
manière de ne pas trop se massacrer il y
a assez peu d'ambition une façon de
survivre et une manière de se connaître
euh or aujourd'hui on voit très bien
dans la jeunesse qui a envie de
s'impliquer sur le proch il y a une
envie d'agiter des drapeaux comme si
c'était un match de football or pour moi
revenir à l'humain c'est également
mettre un petit peu de côté les
compétences de géopoliticiens que
personne n'a et que tout le monde agite
et juste revenir à quelque chose le
pragmatisme maghrébin ça me plaît
beaucoup par exemple dans le silence qui
a suivi le 7 octobre les Juifs se sont
sentis très seuls je vous seraai sans
doute surpris mais les premiers qui
m'ont écrit ou qui m'ont appelé ce sont
des amis maghrébains et des amis
iraniens ils m'ont pas du tout appelé
pour me demander mon avis sur de Proche
Orient ou me parler du détail parce
qu'ils savent très bien qu'on sera pas
d'accord pour des raisons d'affinité
mais en revanche j'ai eu des coups de
fil d'amis maghrébins et d'amis iraniens
tout simplement comment vas-tu et et
cette simplicité là moi j'y suis très
sensible et et il y a une tentation dans
les événements actuels de nous déchirer
et de dire ah bah voilà le choc Orient
Occident dont dont révit les Le Pen on
l'a maintenant moi je pense qu'on a le
droit de dire que le futur ressemblera à
ce qu'on décide et et de toute façon
construire l'avenir c'est construire
l'avenir avec les gens qui qui sont
vivants la seule chose que j'ai à dire
sur le proche- Orient c'est que les gens
qui s'imaginent que les 8 millions et
demi d'Israéliens vont disparaître ne
sont pas pour la paix et les gens qui
s'imaginent que les Palestiniens vont
disparaître ne sont pas pour la paix
donc comme personne va aller nulle part
un jour peut-être dans longtemps parce
que peut-être qu'on a pris 20 temps de
retard mais un jour il faudra que ces
gens se parlent vous avez perdu des amis
aussi ah oui oui j'ai perdu des amis à
qui je parle plus c'est des gens qui
n'ont aucun lien de près ou de loin avec
le Proche Orient qui ne connaissent rien
sur le sujet et qui depuis leur fauteuil
expliquent la vie ça ça me rend fou ça
ça moi j'ai jamais d'opinion je je dès
que je dis une opinion je me dis j'ai eu
tort on pourrait penser l'inverse et
cetera le le quand un conflit est vieux
comme celui du Proche Orient quand il a
75 ans il y a du vrai dans les deux
narratifs quand j'écoute le narratif
palestinien sur le fait que 700000
personnes on ont été exilés en 1948
c'est vrai quand j'écoute le narratif
israélien ou juif qui consiste à dire
que plus d'un million de Juifs ont été
foutus dehors du monde arabe entre les
années 20 et les années 60 c'est vrai
aussi ces gens-là aujourd'hui c'est euh
65 % des citoy israélien et c'est 5
millions de personnes pour les
Palestiniens tout ça c'est vrai donc les
imbéciles qui derrière leur télé ont des
opinions tranchées moi ça me rend fou et
il en avait parmi vos amis donc en tout
cas il y a des gens à qui je parle plus
ou moins pour comprendre votre œuvre et
qui vous êtes exactement il faut évoquer
vos origines votre enfance vos cultures
un père juif sphara d'Algérie une maman
juivequenas d'Ukraine qui meurt quand
vous avez 3 ans mais dont le père votre
grand-père va être très présent tout au
long de votre enfance quand votre mère
meurt elle n'a que 26 ans et on vous dit
qu'elle est partie en voyage un mensonge
d'adulte euh que vous auriez pu mal
prendre après coup mais non vous les
remercierz aujourd'hui parce que vous
dites que grâce à ça vous avez appris et
je vous cite à raconter des histoires et
à en faire votre métier c'est très beau
je trouve ça très indulgent aussi non
enfin j'ai j'ai eu vraiment deux mal on
parle de masculinité toxique j'ai eu
deux mals dominants dans mon enfance mon
grand-père qui était un juif ukrainien
dont toute la famille était morte dans
la Choa parbal et donc qui était
niiliste antireligieux alors qu'il avait
fait des études pour devenir Rabin et
mon père qui était un avocat né en
Algérie favorable à l'indépendance
algérienne il était dans les soutiens de
ferratabas il a quitté l'Algérie en 57
et dès qu'il était en France il s'est
mis à combattre juridiquement les
néonazis c'est un des avocats qui a fait
mettre en prison des néonazis dans les
années 7080 donc entre ces deux figures
moi je trouvais pas ma place enfin c
difficile et c'est vrai quand ma mère
est morte mon père a exigé que personne
me le dise il voulait pas que j'ai du
chagrin et mon grand-père donc le papa
de ma maman m'a dit la vérité 2 ans
après donc j'ai grandi entre ces deux
types h votre mère avait eu un parcours
atypique un champion de natation je
crois de tubes dans la chanson notamment
sur une composition au piano de votre
père des études de pharmacie vous dites
une femme solaire joyeuse même la plus
joyeuse de Nice vous dites que vous
n'avez pas de souvenir d'elle mais que
vous avez en vous un vide qu'elle a
laissé et que vous comblez avec le
dessin parce que ça veut dire que le
dessin est aussi apparu par instinct de
survie affective oui c'est très vrai je
ma maman a été élue mademoiselle âge
tendre quand elle était petite c'est
comme Miss France mais pour les plus
jeunes euh j'ai très peu de souvenirs
d'elle et mon dessin n'est pas un projet
esthétique mon dessin c'est un projet
totemique George Steiner dirait que je
cherche de réell présence et et j'ai
dessiné depuis tout petit pour faire
apparaître des choses qui me manquaient
ou des choses qui me faisaient plaisir
et peut-être aussi devenir narrateur
c'est être un peu maître de son destin
et et je dois dire j'interviens beaucoup
en milieu scolaire et en milieu
universitaire et j'engage la jeunesse à
écrire ses propres histoires parce que
c'est une façon aussi d'échapper à la
manipulation qu'elle soit familiale
qu'elle soit politique il y a une
manière de dire je suis le héros de ma
propre histoire elle a pas moins de
valeur que celle des autres et je vais
tenter de la raconter c'est intéressant
parce que j'allais envenir à cette
question rituelle dans dans l'émission à
la lueur de celui que vous êtes
aujourd'hui quel conseil donneriez-vous
au petit garçon que vous étiez ou au
jeune homme en devenir je suis pas sûr
que j'en donnerai parce que je crois pas
que les vieux soient plus intelligents
que les petits je d'abord on n'est pas
la même personne quand on est grand non
je lui poserai sans doute des questions
parce que je sais plus trop qui était
cette personne je sais que quand je
rencontre quand je rencontre des jeunes
gens c'est surtout l'idée de pas avoir
peur l'idée de faire une chose dont on a
envie quand on se lève le matin l'idée
de de de de moi je suis un élève
amoureux de Clément Rosset qui a été mon
mon prof de philo et qui disait dès
qu'on approfondit on quitte le réel moi
je crois beaucoup à cette idée faire un
truc qu'on a envie de faire le matin euh
ça suffit comme projet pour moi c'est
pas mal comme conseil dans le judaïsme
les représentations sont interdites le
dessin est très limité voire proscrit
votre vie à vous votre vocation c'est le
dessin euh il y a il y a une façon
d'être allée contre les précepts
bibliques préceptes bibliques il y a
quelque chose de il y a de la rébellion
en vous aussi vis-à-vis de ça en tout
bon je crois pas qu'on puisse être
seulement juif je crois moi je suis
aussi bien chrétien que juif que musulm
qu'agnostique puisque on est dans un
creusé multiculturel il est vrai
l'enseignement qui soit juif ou musulman
est iconoclaste et voit l'image d'un
mauvais œil alors on peut l'accepter
mais enfin ça pose problème dans le
monde chrétien la la querelle
iconoclaste a été réglé au début de
l'ère chrétienne et on est dans un monde
de représentation il y a aussi chez moi
l'influence grecque et l'idée de de
refuser la représentation parce que
comme dans la caverne de Platon c'est ce
dont il faut se détourner pour
s'investir dans la cité c'est une
question qui est ouverte chez moi est-ce
que le dessin c'est une manière de
s'évader du réel et donc de tourner le
dos au monde pour le dire autrement
quand il y a des drames dans le monde
est-ce que j'ai raison de dessiner des
petits chats ah peut-être peut-être pas
il y a Leila Slimani qui a donné une
réponse que je trouve très belle elle
dit la la liberté que donne la
littérature donc la liberté que donne
l'invention peut soigner le réel
c'est-à-dire quand on fait ce pas de
côté en disant je sais pas si tu de
l'idolâtrie je sais pas si c'est du rêve
je sais pas mais je suis libre je suis
libre de de faire parler un personnage
qui pense l'inverse de moi je suis libre
d'explorer une thèse qui me paraît
révoltante bon ça va peut-être être
utile ça va peut-être être utile donc
voilà ouais et vous parliez de votre
père et du fait qu'il ait fait de la
politique c'est un grand avocat mais qui
a aussi fait de la politique est-ce
qu'il y a de la politique dans vos
intentions de dessinateur est-ce que
parfois vous dessinez avec des
intentions politiques un regard oui un
engagement non parce que je moi j'ai pas
beaucoup d'admiration pour les auteurs
qui pensent que leur plume a de
l'influence je pense que c'est ridicule
par rapport à Kenny West on n pas
beaucoup d'influence par rapport à cyil
Hanouna non plus une bande dessinée ça
se vend pas autant en revanche être
sincère j'allais dire avec soi-même ne
pas avoir d'autocensure et se dire mon
lectorat est assez mur pour se faire une
opinion ça c'est peut-être politique par
exemple on m'a on m'a interrogé
récemment sur des personnalités
politiques françaises je me sentais pas
en mesure de parler de leur politique ou
de leur bilan en revanche parler du
personnage dresser le portrait dire la
gestuelle moi je suis portraitiste donc
ça me dit quelque chose moi quand je
parle de judaïsme c'est pas pour faire
changer les opinions c'est parce que ça
me préoccupe et je crois que mes
lecteurs et moi on a une petite
discussion qui mérite de se continuer
mais j'ai pas envie de les faire changer
d'avis par exemple j'ai un document à
vous montrer Johann Spar c'est un un
document qui nous a été transmis par nos
partenaires sur cette émission les
Archives nationales vous inquiétez pas
je vais le déchiffrer hein vois mettre
vos lunettes c'est le cas de plein de
nos invités mais je vais lire il s'agit
d'une lettre adressée au ministre des
Cultes envoyé par le Consistoire des
Israélites d'orant elle annonce la
nomination du Rabin de thlemsen ville
algérienne Moïse Moïse pardon Veil nous
sommes alors en décembre
1877 époque où vivent pas loin de 8000
juifs à Tlemsen sur 23000 habitants
environ avant l'indépendance de la
Algérie la communauté juive représentait
130000 personnes aujourd'hui ils sont
une poignée qu'on a du mal à chiffrer en
tout cas ils sont très peu nombreux
est-ce qu'il y a un peu de nostalgie
chez vous de cette époque où juifs et
musulmans pouvaient quand même cohabiter
vivre ensemble enfin moi l'époque où
juifs et musulmans cohabit je la vis en
France depuis que je suis né hein moi je
suis un juif maghrébain la plupart de
mes copains sont maghrébains il est plus
question de fraternité que de
cohabitation il est question d'histoire
commune je moi j'ai jamais eu de
problème ni avec les individus ni avec
les religieux ni rien on est juste
balloté et broyé par l'histoire prenons
la citoyenneté des Juifs d'Algérie parce
que c'est tout de même formidable ce
sont des Juifs qui étaient dans le
Maghreb depuis l'Antiquité depuis bien
avant les invasions arabes ils sont
arrivés avec les Berbères ils sont
arrivés avec l'Empire romain ils sont
arrivver ensuite avec l'Empire ottoman
en 1870 grâce à Crémieux on leur donne
la nationalité française bon ok ensuite
sous Pétin on la leur retire bon ok
ensuite après Pétin on la leur rend
d'accord et ensuite quand il y a la
guerre d'Algérie on les renvoie en
métropole comme si c'était chez eux or
aucun d'entre eux ne venait de métropole
et on les a appelé des Juifs piednoirs
ce qui est complètement absurde
puisqu'il venaent il venaent quand on
pense la l'inspiratrice des Berbères la
reine Cena à ma connaissance elle
s'appelait Cohen donc ouis quel quel est
votre rapport à ce pays à l'Algérie vous
y allez de temps en temps vous y êtes
allé j'ai jamais mis un seul pied en
Algérie mais j'ai eu la chance de
grandir à Nice avec des Algériens de
tout bord qui qui en parlit comme s'ils
y étaient encore donc il me semble que
ça ressemble et et et moi je suis
l'enfant d'une Algérie qui n'existe plus
et c'est pas une nostalgie c'est une un
souvenir familial que j'adore partager
avec des gens de ma génération qui
viennent de familles musulmanes de
familles chrétiennes qui ont qui ont
aussi ce ce rapport ambivalent au
Maghreb vous ne ressentez pas l'envie
d'aller en Algérie elle est présente
partout dans votre œuvre vous pour le
chat du Rabin dont le tome 12 est sorti
c'est cette vie en Algérie vous dites
les racontards de ma grand-mère qui me
parlait de CTIF d'Alger de
Constantine même que vous sentez
maghrébin vous n'avez pas envie d'y
aller non non parce que je suis niceois
l'endroit où je suis né où j'ai grandi
c'est Nice l'Algérie c'est l'histoire de
ma grand-mère et de mon père en revanche
j'aimais beaucoup leurs histoires et et
j'aime j'ai énormément de lecteurs en
Algérie malheureusement moins parmi les
autorités mais mais parmi les vrais
êtres humains j'en ai plein au au Maroc
et en Tunisie aussi et moi j'ai toujours
moi quand je dis le Maghreb pour moi
c'est ici j'ai l'impression pardon si ça
choque des gens mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on est un pays en en petite en petite
majorité maghrébine en tout cas il
important le Maghreb en France donc j'ai
pas besoin de traverser la Méditerranée
pour le voir cependant si on m'invite un
jour je serai ravi d'y aller mais c'est
pas quelque chose d'important à mes yeux
moi je quand quand je parle d'Algérie je
raconte mes souvenirs des films de du
Vivier c'est Pépé le moco c'est tout ça
c'est les histoires de ma grand-mère et
c'est la ville de Nice c'est la
communauté de Juifs d'Algérie qui était
à Nice quand j'étais petit vous aimeriez
qu'elle vous invite les autorités
algériennes quand même vous seriez
touché vous diriez que peut-être vous
comptez pour eux non c'est c'est quelque
chose de c'est quelque chose de plus
vaste la la la blessure profonde
du du monde juif et du monde arabe c'est
le départ de tous les Juifs du monde
arabe tout au long du 20e siècle et
c'est d'autant plus absurde que ce sont
des cultures qui ont tout pour
s'entendre et la chose que je suis pas
le seul à penser d'ailleurs les
massacres du 7 octobre ils ont fait quoi
ils ont mis un point d'arrêt à la
réconciliation d'Israël et de tous ses
voisins arabes parce que qu'est-ce qui
était en train de se passer c'était en
train de marcher avec des ennemis
historiques comme l'Arabie Saoudite les
Israéliens étaient en train de se
réconcilier ça ça a été insupportable
sans doute pour l'Iran pour le Qatar et
le Hamas qui ont téléguidé ces massacres
mais parce que moi j'essaie toujours
d'avoir de l'espoir si on recule un peu
il me semble que la paix était sur le
point de se faire dans cette région et
ce que personne dit en ce moment dans
les télévisions c'est que les relations
n'ont pas du tout cessé entre Israël et
le monde arabe depuis les massacres du 7
octobre il continuent il avoir des ils
se font moins publiquement mais ils
existent toujours et et je crois qu'il y
a beaucoup de gens dans le monde arabe
euh qui sont très peinés de ces
événements et qui ont hâte que la paix
puisse venir un jour et ça j'en parle
parce que au niveau individuel et depuis
30 ans que je travaille je n'ai que des
échanges éblouissants avec le monde
arabe et aussi avec le monde persan donc
je je je vois pas pourquoi ça
n'adiendrait pas un jour et quand on se
raconte ça c'est un mensonge quand on se
raconte que le conflit israélo-arabe
date depuis toujours c'est complètement
débile ça date de l'écroulement de
l'Empire ottoman parce que tout
simplement quand l'Empire ottoman s'est
écroulé il y a eu la montée des
nationalismes arabes et une envie de la
part des Juifs d'avoir un pays et ils
ont pas attendu 1948 pour aller au
proche- Orient donc on est en train de
vivre les soubressau de ce qu'il est
resté du colonialisme et je fais partie
des gens qui pensent pas que ça durera
toujours vous avez dit un jour je
cherche toujours par ma petite histoire
personnelle à toucher quelque chose
d'universel si ça ne touche pas tout le
monde je n'y vais pas mes livres sont
faits pour les autres travailler pour
moi-même ça ne m'intéresse pas je
préfère manger des frites je vous cite
quand vous publiez Youngman qui est
recueil de vos croquis d'étudiants euh
retrouver d'ailleurs lors de votre
déménagement je crois donc un peu par
hasard vous décidez d'en faire quelque
chose qu'est-ce que vous dites à l'autre
quel est le message universel de
Youngman par exemple il y en a pas il y
en a pas parce que tous les carnets que
je publie maintenant j'en ai publié
plein je sais que je m'adresse aux gens
je me dis ça s'adresse à tout le monde
je vais parler de mon intimité mais il
faut que ça intéresse les gens Youngman
ce sont les dessins que je faisais quand
personne voulait me publier donc c'est
rageux c'est morbide c'est un jeune mec
qui arrête pas de se mettre en colère
contre les rares éditeurs qui accepte de
le recevoir et et c'est d'autant plus
débile que j'étais très joyeux à
l'époque mais ce que je notais comme les
jeunes qui se sentent un peu gothiques
je notais que des trucs un peu déprimant
oui mais le fait qu'ils ne soit pas
censé être lu est-ce que ils sont du
coup plus authentiques est-ce qu'il y a
quelque chose de plus vrai dans ces
carnets que dans les œuvres où vous
savez que vous allez les publier
qu'elles sont dessinées un public ce
n'est pas le cas des carnet c'est
beaucoup plus impudique en tout cas
c'est c'est beaucoup plus impudique que
aujourd'hui quand je fais des carnets je
crois que j'écris jamais mes pensées
sombres ou mes pensées noires je peux
être en colère je peux être scandalisé
mais je met en forme pour les gens en
revanche dans Youngman on a accès à la
noirceur d'un jeune homme ave avec le
recul je trouve ça charmant parce que j
c'est mignon mais je pense sur le moment
je devais être vraiment triste parfois
mais on a peut-être accès à vous
directement plus au travers des carnets
que de vos œuvres alors je suis plus la
même personne je suis vraiment plus la
même personne je je vous évoluez comme
le chat oui je vous êtes le chat j'étais
le chat je deviens le Rabin mais pas
parce que je suis plus sage mais parce
que je suis est-ce que vous êtes un peu
ce chat qui évolue d'ailleurs qu'on voit
évoluer au fil il y a les de il y a
toujours quelqu moi j'ai toujours je
rêve toujours d'être aussi aussi
anarchiste que le chat et en vrai je
suis parfois un père de famille contre
comme le Rabin donc ça ça ressemble à du
Molière c'est le chat c'est Scapin c'est
le valet c'est tout ça et et le Rabin
c'est le bon père de famille comme on
dit votre façon de fonctionner est
intéressante vous dites que vous n'avez
pas de plan quand vous vous lancez dans
un album dans un ouvrage pas de
structure que vous passez d'une case à
l'autre sans scénario vous dites qu'il
faut laisser du blanc aussi pour laisser
le lecteur libre et j'ai l'impression
que votre œuvre elle est très libre et
que c'est ça qui la caractérise le plus
cette liberté incroyable y compris
d'ailleurs de laisser les personnages
libr d'évoluer librement un peu au
dehors de vous quoi c'est c'est très
difficile d'écrire une histoire parce
que les spectateurs sont de plus en plus
mûs donc pour les cueillir pour les
surprendre il faut pas qu'ils arrivent à
prévoir ce qui va se passer donc mon
petit secret c'est de réfléchir à
l'histoire le plus longtemps possible
mais ça peut être un an là le dernier
chat du Rabin qui s'appelle la traversée
de la Mer Noire ça fait 10 ans que j'y
réfléchis et que je rassemble des
document et une fois qu'on a une vague
idée de l'histoire on se dit tiens je
pourrais me lever à table et la raconter
à l'oral et ben là il faut écrire d'un
coup parce que là les personnages vont
faire des petites surprises vont faire
des choses qu'on attend pas mais en
revanche dire une structure avant c'est
s'exposé à ne pas surprendre son
lectorat je crois je crois que le cinéma
aussi le montage vous a un peu changé
enfin a changé votre façon de travailler
maintenant vous pouvez écrire les cases
et les mettre dans un certain ordre à la
toute fin une fois que vous avez tout
écrit un peu comme un film au montage on
peut faire un peu ce qu'on veut le le
montage ça m'a beaucoup appris et alors
ça la fout mal pour un juif mais Louis
Ferdinand séine aussi Louis Ferdinand
séine il avait une technique d'écriture
que je trouve formidable il écrivait sur
des feuilles vierges et il mettait les
chapitres avec des pinces à linge et
ensuite il pouvait on voit dans ses
réécritures il pouvait changer l'ordre
des pages il pouvait retirer un chapitre
ça c'est du montage de cinéma et au
cinéma la première fois où j'ai vu des
gens de cinéma j'ai eu la chance de de
voir travailler claud Chabrol le montage
se faisait encore avec de la colle et du
film et ça ça voulait dire que quand on
coupait ça voulait vraiment dire quelque
chose aujourd'hui c'est tellement facile
de monter que les choses ont moins
d'importance mais le montage de cinéma a
changé ma manière d'écrire les bandes
dessiné ça c'est sûr ça é un vrai tourno
j'ai des photos à vous proposer Johann
Spar c'est un rituel un autre dans cette
émission on aime bien les rituels
première photo c'est Catherine Meuris
dessinatrice autrice de bande dessiné
élu en 2020 à l'Académie des Beaux Arts
une première dans l'histoire je vous la
monre parce que je sais que la question
des femmes dans la BD vous touche en
2016 vous avez demandé à être retiré de
la liste des nommés au grand prix du
festival d'angoulem parce qu'aucune
dessinatrice ne figurait sur la liste
enfin je crois vous allez peut-être me
le confirmer le monde de la BD a du mal
ou a eu du mal à s'ouvrir aux femmes oui
oui euh pour une raison historique après
guerre les stocks de papiers alors
pendant la deème Guerre mondiale les
bandes dessinées américaines étaient
interdites par le le gouvernement Pétin
après guerre figurez-vous que les
communistes les golistes et les Catau se
sont mis d'accord pour faire pour
perpétuer cet interdit pour pouvoir
promouvoir une bande dessinée française
ils avaient des stocks de papiers cette
bande dessinée française ça a été Pif
Gadget d'un côté et les revu Cato de
l'autre et ben dans ces revues il y
avait pas de femmes les personnages
étaient tous masculins euh ça a donné en
Belgique c'était la même chose et ça a
cherché un lectorat masculin et ce
lectorat c'est devenu les dessinateurs
de bande dessiné au même moment au Japon
se développait une bande dessiné dont
les auteurs étaient autant des femmes
que des hommes les personnages autant
des femmes que des hommes ce qui fait
qu'au Japon il y a des femmes autrices
depuis toujours j'ai une deuxième photo
j'avais envie de vous parler du CE
anniversaire de Disney alors Disney
c'est un peu aux antipodes de votre
univers he de vos dessins des dessins
animés qui sont à l'épreuve ces
dernières années de ce qu'on appelle le
wisme cette tendance wiste la firme de
Mickey se retrouve ces dernières années
au cœur d'une guerre culturelle
américaine et on commence à écrire ou à
réécrire des œuvres en fonction des
minorités est-ce que l'idée vous rebut
vous effraie ou vous séduit est-ce que
vous pourriez faire cela avec vos
propres œuvres moi je voudrais qu'on ait
du temps pour parler de ces sujets pour
pas les caricaturer je vous parle d'un
scandale récent parce que tout le monde
a menti si ament ou pas il y a quelques
mois on vous a dit c'est scandaleux tout
le monde veut réécrire l'œuvre de
roaldal on censure roaldal sauf qu'on y
regardant de plus près c'est la famille
de roaldal qui a décidé de réécrire pour
des raisons commciales parce parce qu'il
y a certains clichés racistes ou
sexistes qui passent plus aujourd'hui
donc il faut être assez attentif Disney
je trouve qu'ils s'en sortent pas si mal
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne modifi pas leur
dessin animé si on les voit sur Disney
plus mais par contre ça ouvre avec un
carton attention dans ce Desset animé il
y a des clichés qui n'iraient plus
aujourd'hui ce qui est pas tout à fait
faux je regrette les les corbeaux qui
ont l'air noir dans Dumbo les Indiens
dans peterp franchement il y a moyen de
faire mieux vous nêtes pas complètement
contre l'idée de modifier un petit peu
l'œvre moi non je je suis pour prendre
conscience de la société dans laquelle
on vit on est aujourd'hui qu'on le
veuille ou non dans une société
multiculturelle et et je pense qu'on on
sait bien que tout public soit capable
d'apprécier une œuvre ou de la recevoir
et et et peut-être la chose la plus
intéressante ce serait de garder les
œuvres historiques telles qu'elles sont
mais en les contextualisant c'est-à-dire
en disant oui Tintin au Congo c'est pas
l'œuvre la plus progressiste qu'on
puisse imaginer en revanche est capable
de produire aujourd'hui des œuvres
nouvelles qui par exemple un exemple qui
me tient à cœur mon auteur préféré
d'enfance c'est Tolkien moi j'aime
Tolkien au-delà de tout bon quand on
ouvre Tolkien on on peut se le raconter
comme on veut tous les héros sont blancs
c'est bon machin mais tant mieux c'est
des super romans mais qu'on invente
aujourd'hui de nouveaux romans avec des
héros de chevalerie issu d'autres
peuples d'autres histoires d'autres
mystiques j'ai une dernière question qui
est en lien avec le lieu dans lequel
nous sommes Johann spard nous sommes
entourés de quatre statues qui
représente chacune une vertu il y a la
sagesse la prudence la justice et
l'éloquence est-ce qu'il y a une de ces
vertus qui vous inspirerait peut-être un
personnage une œuvre ou qui vous
caractérise vous moi je suisil d'avocat
alors l'éloquence ça me plaît beaucoup
je crois que vous alliez dire la justice
oh non non s'il est avocat il croit pas
en la justice c'est pas on parle d'un
avocat quand même les médecins Vous
j'arrête avec Céline mais cette super
phrase dans le Voyage au bout de la nuit
il y a deux médecins en train d'opérer
il y en a un qui dit et vous chers
collègues vous y croyez en la médecine
bon mon père avocat à Nice qu'est-ce que
vous vouz c'est la même chose non moi je
crois pas beaucoup à la vérité donc il
me semble que l'éloquence c'est pas mal
la manière dont vous voyez une personne
être capable de vous de vous vendre des
salades avec un truc et de vous vendre
l'invers au lendemain ça me fascine
ouais mentir sur la marchandise moi les
avocats j'adore merci Joan Spar d'avoir
été notre invité dans un monde un regard
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi comme
chaque semaine émission que vous pouvez
retrouver je vous le rappelle en podcast
n'hésitez pas à très bientôt merci à
[Musique]
vous